FDA has failed to enforce their own
rules as imitation products have used
DA's good name for their own benefit are
you too stupid to tell the difference
between cow's milk and non-dairy milk
this politician thinks so a Bill in
Congress would ban plant-based products
from using terms like milk meaning your
favorite brand of oat milk would have to
use an awkward label like oat beverage
politicians say this is to help
consumers but is anyone actually
confused about this Americans can tell
the difference between vegan milk and
the real thing so what's really
behind this extremely difficult times
this is another example of government
trying to prop up a struggling industry
but it's not almond milk's fault
Americans are simply choosing to consume
less cow's milk by forcing vegan
manufacturers to use clunky terms the
government wants to confuse you into
buying more cow's milk but these
politicians should stop cow to to Dairy
Farmers and let Americans make their own
choices